oh is there anything worse than you
you're in public and you just have to go
and you sit down you're like
the seat's warm like oh the four times
i've probably taken the [ __ ] in public
in my life
only four yeah i that i don't think this
towards it's been
as clean i take everything i wipe the
soap down i think i purel it
everything everything and then i kind of
hover it's never like a full size oh
yeah
oh i don't you cry freeze up though
somebody walks into bathroom like
[ __ ] i don't wanna hear the plop
are you afraid to poop in public no
don't give a flying [ __ ] yeah
germaphobe none of that i mean for me
the the
the the airport bathroom is a place that
i try to avoid
just because if it's just generally not
the cleanest
but i'm with you man you don't care at
all game on planes i don't give a [ __ ]
planes planes on the planes i try to
hurry
no i don't want this because stewart
stoy's right next to the door so i don't
want to be like damn dooky boy so
i hurry and i wash my hands to get the
smell of the soap
then i open the door do you ever time it
you're like this is how long a piss
could take so
i'm gonna i'm gonna make sure i'm not in
here longer than if i'm in there long
then i'll pretend i'm on my phone
which doesn't make sense now because of
the huh
yeah i'm in the air okay the flight
attendant is like why does your phone
smell like [ __ ]
i always rub my hands when i come out of
the bathroom yeah people know i washed
them yeah we thought we like this
move
yeah i like to wear when i go to the
bathroom a plane taking [ __ ] i'll rub my
hands i'll pretend i forgot so i'm like
what the
[ __ ] i have to tell you i am
anti-pooping on planes you shouldn't
poop on tour buses you shouldn't poop on
airplanes
for me if it's an emergency i get it but
if i can hold
it i don't get out of my seat on the
plane i don't pee i
i pee before i get on the plane i lean
up against the window and i go to sleep
the worst if you got a window
and the guy next to you just takes the
tray down his laptop and everything like
this
if i got a piss he's not gonna be happy
yeah i apologize like ten times sorry i
got it
me too bathroom i'm sorry and then
finally you know i'll just tell like
yeah
and then you're like but then you're
stuck you don't wanna get them twice
though
i know yes i gotta i'll hold it so i
can't hold it anymore because i
just want to get up once i don't want to
bother this dude twice it's so stressful
yeah you have to say that's a stressful
situation like
sending emails
[ __ ] like right there he's about to
transfer the money from his 401k
excuse me yeah i i i my stock just went
down [ __ ]
yeah are you a chatty kathy on the plane
no man
i have headphones in seven ends a a's
and ends no man
i don't want you talking to me my
headphones are in my my
my hoodie's on and and that's i just
don't
i'm not ready for small talk i'm gonna
be saying
i just don't want to do it the energy
the worst is when they go
where you headed yeah same place you are
bruh we're on the same plane no i don't
i hate
telling them what i do oh yeah because
if you say comedians
nothing they say you only get three
responses
it's either they try to tell you a joke
that's long
or they want you to tell them a joke or
they ask you do i
do you know somebody and we're the only
profession they do that because
it's i always say like you'll say i'm a
comedian and you know frank smith from
milwaukee yeah
like this how would i be on tv or
anything no no he's a local guy
how the [ __ ] yeah they don't go out to
lebron james you know david jackson
basketball the ymca in torrance yeah
that guy's a beast on tuesday night
no how would i know him we bought my
basketball that guy's a beast
either ask someone like really like low
like that or like
what do you think kevin hart man funny
right yeah yeah yeah sure dude
the worst thing they tell you a joke
yeah and you're just going how long is
this joke and you got you always
getting the fake laugh
when they try to tell you somebody
else's joke that you know is funny
you know kevin hart's joke and they tell
you this butcher and i'm like are you
telling people that's kevin hart's joke
because that was not it like that's the
[ __ ] worst thing
i i will tell you though man or or they
go the way if you're flying to kansas
city go can't see
we playing that bro maybe i'll go maybe
you know what maybe we'll go
friday and saturday yeah man [ __ ] yeah
and super awkward they're sitting right
next to you like can i get a couple
tickets
and i'm like i don't want to say no
right to your face but no yeah or
or or they go or they go so how would i
go about getting tickets like like any
other
god are you talking about this
this weekend my opener i live an hour
for the san francisco airport he goes
hey man uh
can i ask him real quick yeah he goes
what's the most efficient way he that's
what he said what's the most official
way to get to your house
from the san francisco airport i go do
you need a ride
is that what you're asking like that's
like a passive dresser
this is someone else's car is that what
you mean that's why i said again i
assume he's like kind of scared of gary
not physically but just like you know
because you're
a famous comic he's probably yeah hey
dude you know like that's his way of
beating around the bush yeah like this
just
uber or bart or i don't know
i always say real friends don't ask
friends pick him up from the airport or
help him move
like you know come on dude yeah come on
man not after a certain
age no you're you're 20 years old what
yeah i can't go there what no dude hour
from my house that's an
hour back to it's two hours out of wow
and we got a show that night there's not
zero
zero chance yeah when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son